[MUSIC]
Folks who take a growth mindset,
see the challenges they're
facing as something that they
could develop enough to achieve or
overcome or master or learn from.
So that a failure from a growth mindset
perspective is an opportunity to learn.
One of the things that goes on when you
are learning in the context of a number of
other people who are different from you,
you're confronted with experiences
that you would never have had.
Now, if you're in a group with
a lot of people who look and
have very different experiences.
And now you begin to share those
experiences, you gain from that
living knowledge about what it's
like to be a very different person.
And they're saying, well, here's what
happened when we used that approach.
And somebody else will raise
their hand and say, yeah, but
here's what happened when we use that
approach, and they're so different.
And that's incredibly educational
from a developmental perspective.
It makes you begin to realize things that
you have been taking for granted, or
possibilities that
you've never considered.
I remember hearing a Ukrainian
mass retailer comparing what
was going on in his organization,
to an executive from Lululemon.
And the learning that came out
of that interaction was amazing,
that diversity allows you to
start thinking of possibilities.
And remember, it's thinking of
possibilities that makes it possible for
us to engage in the developmental
approach to work.
[MUSIC]
>> Question your assumptions and
explore new approaches to leadership.
Explore Stanford's upcoming programs.
[MUSIC]